welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Glass
Onion the second Knives Out who done it
from directory Ryan Johnson I really
enjoyed this film it's Mr X the way the
mystery was structured and that Rascal
Ryan Johnson hid a ton of secrets in the
visuals in the production design Easter
eggs that make re-watching this movie
Super rewarding so let's break down what
you missed we opened with each of Miles
bronze disrupters receiving their
invitation boxes including Governor
Claire she's always in beige with super
self-conscious performative masking
habits during this covet era story set
in may 2020. now while you can see
parallels between Claire and politicians
like Amy Klobuchar or Gretchen Whitmer
her campaign sign in her office does
list her as an independent so she's
probably more of a Kristen Cinema during
her interview with Jake Tapper the
ticker reads Alpha Industries hires new
CFO following messy lawsuit referring to
Andy's falling out with miles now miles
Braun is an analog for eccentric Tech
billionaires like Elon Musk but Ryan
Johnson did write this movie back in
Spring 2020. it wasn't really intended
to be a neon musket job but you know
that fact that many are seen it that way
does tell you something I'll let you
fill in what that something is Lionel
runs miles's company having to interpret
his cryptic faxes notice Lionel's fax
machine has been decorated with devil
horns teeth and Angry Eyes showing how
he is bitterly beholded to Miles
Insanity Duke's mom has already opened
this box seen immediately as a Magic Eye
Style stereogram her Board Puzzle
solving throughout the sequence shows
how miles games are actually not that
smart to a normal person as in the first
Knives Out the answer is always in plain
sight if you just reorient your
perception the chessboard game is
actually set up for a Fool's mate
maneuver this is actually the quickest
possible Checkmate in chess you can do
it in only two moves but it can only
really be done if your opponent is
stupid enough to not really know how
chess Works Yo-Yo Ma cameos so a few is
a beautiful musical puzzle based on just
one tune when you layer this tune on top
of itself it starts to change and turns
into a beautiful new structure this
can't Shazam its own lamp this actually
parallels the film's overall structure
it presents himself as one movie and
then doubles back to layer on top of
itself to turn into a more complex story
this box also includes a Fibonacci
Sequence with the golden ratio of
rectangles framed art that Miles has
over his desk in the Glass Onion which
is where he hides Andy's Red Envelope
now miles invitation reads travel
details to come please forward any
dietary restrictions dietary
restrictions Duke is allergic to
Pineapple something he would have sent
along to Miles and since the island
staff is gone miles is having to do all
the cooking and bartending himself this
is how he knew how to poison Duke Benoit
Blanc plays Among Us with the zoom group
his Avatar is colored white as in Blanc
means white the black one is M she
solved that's Angela Lansbury savitar
who of course played the famous Lutheran
Murder She Wrote Steven Sondheim cameos
Avatar is Fleet Street and not to his
musical Sweeney Todd in which Angela
Lansbury originated the role of Nelly
Stephen Sondheim also wrote the 1973
murder mystery film The Last of Sheila
which Johnson paid homage to with this
opening dock scene sodium was actually
known to host murder mystery parties and
this movie was among hee and Lansbury's
final film appearances the character
Benoit Blanc is a huge Stevenson High
band remember knives out he was rocking
out to sondheim's music from Follies
sometimes I stand in the middle of the
wall Natasha Leon cameos her Avatar is
Big Red she's actually gonna appear in
Ryan Johnson's mystery comedy series
Poker Face in 2023 and then Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar is a huge fan of mysteries
this guy actually wrote several books
about Mycroft homes Sherlock Holmes
brother but the game of Among Us
confuses Benoit Blanc because he is not
good at being an imposter playing these
simple kind of party games which
parallels his role in this movie's plot
he knows he's gonna be spotted
immediately as an outsider and as an
imposter so he enlists Helen so that
they can take the spotlight off of each
other now on the dock each character's
mask reflects their personality benoit's
mask is a Dapper cloth mask that matches
his outfit Claire's mask is beige Lionel
who's a scientist of the group wears a
medically safe m95 birdie wears a
useless mesh mask just like the one Lana
Del Rey got into trouble for wearing now
Ryan Johnson broke down this scene for
Vanity Fair and he said that he shot
each arrival to intercut with benoit's
reaction because knives out he said was
shot from annada armis's perspective
Glass Onion is shown through benoit's
eyes he is really the focal character of
it which is why it takes him and us so
long to see that miles is an idiot but
notice here in the shot where birdie
struts forward that doc according to
Ryan Johnson was too bumpy for a dolly
track so they had to use a jib arm to
keep her centered with all the diagonals
of the shot pointed at her so that when
we cut to Benoit in the reaction shot
his face is in the same part of frame
where we were just looking at birdie
from the shot before there's also some
great physical work from Catherine Han
here did you stop the murder of oh
what's your name the the belly dancer
with the thing and the thing that's you
it is in the flesh I'm obviously
familiar with you all as well Governor
Dr Tucson yeah the moment Benoit calls
her Governor Claire becomes
self-conscious and adjusts her mask back
up to the correct position now
throughout the scene Birdie's massive
hat blocks most of the dock behind her
but Duke and whiskey roll up initially
blocked by nicos's card this is actually
a recurring visual mode scene used by
Johnson like with Birdie's huge hat
blocking Helen's arrival with the pool
scene later or when they all scramble
around the house and the lighthouse
light is going through it and Helen is
in the foreground closest to us things
are always right there in frame they
just tend to be obscured by someone or
something standing in the way and little
detail here as they ask why Ben was
there the assistant Peg is in the
distant background doing leg stretches
she is always forgotten in the
background but gives this thing great
visual depth there's always
in the background of this movie it's
because the cast the cast's so great
Ethan
who gets him on with a throat injection
apparently ethanoc was shooting scenes
for Marvel's Moon Knight over in Hungary
and took a quick day flight to Greece of
all them Benoit seems most comfortable
with throat injection I think because he
already torched that throat with cigars
now on the boat Helen stands beside some
deck chairs with an omega symbol really
this is the Glass Onion symbol it's also
on player's bathrobe later but the fact
that it looks kind of like an Omega does
end up being a clue pointing to Helen as
the future end to Miles Alpha
organization Alpha and the Omega
actually later there's a close-up of
benoit's watch showing it is an Omega
Seamaster the same watch that Daniel
Craig promoted throughout his 007 run
but when Helen walks up off the dock
miles jaw drops he is seeing a ghost
Edward Norton is so great in this movie
in this scene he's playing it both ways
both the shock of seeing a spurn
business partner which is what we think
is the case in this opening act but when
we revisit the scene it also works as a
guy seeing a woman he thought he had
killed Andy
you're here actually the way he touches
our shoulder later it's like he's trying
to put his hand through a ghost I really
am glad you're here
miles is the first of many of fake words
malapropisms and back dares can we just
take a second and fully abbreviate this
moment together in abbreviate you can
actually see Benoit registering it
behind him and other than him only Peg
seems to clock it as wrong actually
based on her eye line she's actually
looking over to Benoit in the shot like
did you also hear that we hear the
hourly dong of the island
[Music]
what is that that's the hourly dong
you know I got full glass to compose
that
what who's Hill gas okay the voice of
the hourly dong is a candy by Joseph
Gordon-Levitt who makes recurring cameos
in Ryan Johnson's movies since he teamed
up with him in Brick he knives out he
voiced the character of detective Hard
Rock in the TV show miles says my puzzle
guy barely got the five done in time and
he apprenticed with Ricky J Ricky J was
a Hollywood magician who often cameo in
films and TV shows but he was also in
Christopher Nolan's a Prestige super
talented super funny guy he was actually
going to Cameo and knives out but he
passed away before he could shoot the
scene and Ryan Johnson paid tribute to
him with a photo of Ricky J on the
fridge in one shot awesome moment here
by the pool Duke talks about miles car
remember that night you almost pancake
me with it on the road outside Anderson
Cooper's birthday
coops parties are memorable ah Duke was
saying the road outside Andy's house
referring to the day Duke saw Miles
leave Andy's house in the day that she
died but miles Cuts him off with
Anderson Cooper's birthday and Ryan
Johnson swings the camera away from Duke
in order to hide its reaction now when
Bernie's hat blocks Ellen sitting beside
her you can actually see the moment
Helen tosses the voice recorder into her
purse he was this little thing in my
hand
yeah you can see a shadow moving behind
her hat right as she says little thing
in my hand the fact that Johnson shot it
from this angle it's just some really
cool attention to detail he didn't want
to lie to us he wanted astute observers
of this movie to have all the clues they
needed to figure it out halfway through
now I have a busy schedule and it only
gets busier this time of year it feels
like there's always a holiday party or
holiday drinks or like a holiday gift
exchange or holiday movie out in or some
kind of holiday plan going on right when
I'd normally be making myself something
to eat if you're running low on time to
cook and still want delicious meals that
you can make at home you should check
out hellofresh hellofresh makes having
fresh meals at home stupidly easy to do
hellofresh has quick and easy options
like 20 minute meals and easy cleanup
dishes they taste awesome and are easy
to make so you can spend less time in
the kitchen more time debating the rules
of your family's white elephant gift
exchange with your siblings and if you
want to bring something with you you'll
find what you need at hellofresh Market
they've got everything from charcuterie
boards to desserts so you'll never have
to be the one showing up empty-handed if
you're traveling over the holidays hella
precious plans that work with your
schedule you can change your meal
preferences your delivery day and
address in just a few clicks so being
away from home doesn't mean being out of
control of what you eat I recently made
some delicious beef flautas they made me
feel like a real professional cook
cooking some yummy beef flautas today
with hello fresh I have um sliced some
onions but I've also uh thinly thinly
diced in minced one might say sub onions
or as the people who make this kind of
food say
boyas I now have my meat cooking it's
got onions some spices in it some ground
beef it smells so good look at me I'm
cooking okay I laid out my flautas now
it's time to me to try to roll these
wahoo
hello to us get outers thanks solo fresh
to get started go to hellofresh.com and
use the code rockstars21 for 21 free
meals plus free shipping once again
that's hellofresh.com and use the code
rockstars21 for 21 free meals plus free
shipping now miles says he doesn't have
a phone he only uses facts which is
actually a kind of callback by Ryan
Johnson to knives out when he said that
Apple doesn't allow villainous
characters to be seen with their
products on screen which I don't think
is true in all movies by the way but it
is a rule that Ryan Johnson sticks to
and knives out Ransom Chris Evans
character uses an Android and in Glass
Onion miles does own an iPad but we
never actually see him holding it he
just tosses it to Benoit with the Apple
logo clearly visible and from that point
forward that's when miles escalates his
villainy now of course miles has filled
his living room with famous paintings
including rothko's number 207 which I
love this miles stupidly hung upside
down because the guy truly doesn't know
or really appreciate art he also has a
huge portrait of himself shirtless this
is actually Edward Norton's face placed
on Brad Pitt's torso from Fight Club
it's painted in the style of France
bacon and all these various paintings
are from completely different eras and
styles and genres miles clearly just
picked them for their monetary value
making this place a tacky uncomfortable
Museum like the Hearst castle and not
really a comfortable home now miles
hands each of them cocktail glasses with
their names embossed on them but poor
Peg later has to write her name on a
Solo Cup miles talks about the Mona Lisa
You Know da Vinci invented a technique
for brush Strokes that leave no lines
that's how you can look straight at her
and her expression changes every time
this does call back the portrait of
Harlan thrombian knives out which change
from frown in the beginning of the movie
to smiling at the end of it the dining
table area is a greek temple with a
mural of of course Kanye West as a Roman
senator in otoga now later while they
sit around getting drunk Claire gets a
call from her husband but she silences
it this is him probably alerting her
about the breaking news of Andy's death
but Duke is constantly checking his
phone for his Google Alerts and notice
as he hugs miles early on in this scene
you can totally see Andy's obituary on
his phone screen but notice Duke hides
it once birdie tries to see the phone
and right after this miles goes straight
over the bar and you can actually see
him pouring pineapple juice in his cup
and he does indeed hand this class to
Duke as birdie spins despite him later
saying Duke just accidentally picked up
the wrong cup we saw with our eyes all
of this go down in the First Act of the
movie you can see clearly through to the
center of the Glass Onion if you
actually watch this movie closely so all
those complaining that the first half of
this movie lied or deceived us even
though that's totally okay for whodunits
to do I think those critics are really
masking other reasons they dislike this
movie the kind of reasons I'm not really
that interested in this movie absolutely
gives us all the pieces to see miles
murder Duke and why he does it long
before we get anywhere near the second
half trust me
it's all in plain sight but you can
actually see the moment Daniel Craig's
face when Benoit figures it out is he
choking I think yeah I think oh no he's
not joking
it's really subtle but you can see
Daniel Craig's nostril Flair he is
smelling the pineapple juice and he
remembers what Duke said on the dock
again a line that we all heard no
pineapple on that right Duke don't dance
with pineapple there's no pineapple
there's also a pretty clear red flag
that Miles stole Duke's phone my old
I'm just gonna silence Duke's phone
we're staying right here in this room
I'm keeping you all in plain sight until
that boat arrives where's Duke's phone
it just dinged it must be here yeah yeah
Benoit didn't hear it dinging from the
body he heard it dinging from Miles back
pocket which was right in front of the
body and when Peg approaches miles knows
I'm mild scampers away so that she won't
see it in his pocket or be able to
locate where the phone is he needs to
get away from her so we can silence it
so in the sequence where they're
scrambling through the darkness the
hallway painting next to Miles shows
four pop icons whose name's all rhyme
you got Iggy Pop Biggie Smalls Twiggy
and Ziggy Stardust Iggy piggy Twiggy
Ziggy it's so stupid when Benoit runs
back into Helen he does call her by her
real name Helen this is actually the
first time we hear the name Helen in
this movie so as Benoit starts to
explain to everyone what happened notice
the glass sculpture to the left actually
resembles the knife wheel from the
thrombi house and knives out so the
midpoint of the movie begins with the
same framing as the opening shot of the
film a hand knocking on the door because
this movie is essentially starting over
from the beginning Hugh Grant cameos has
been was partner Philip he's covered in
flower and holding Yeast Starter as many
during covet took up bread baking Helen
tries to hire Benoit as in her words the
world's greatest detective but he
responds I'm not Batman Batman's moniker
of course the world's greatest detective
but listen closely a moment later no
that's outrageous I wouldn't I
will now
wow no that yes uh as benwell starts to
form his plan in his head the score does
sample The Melody of Danny elfman's
Batman theme so when the bar flashback
the original Glass Onion miles is
dressed like Tom Cruise's Alpha bro
motivational speaker for Magnolia
fitting that he would name this company
Alpha actually when miles first sees
Andy drawing up her business plan on the
cocktail napkin he lines up what should
be an easy Corner shot on the pool table
but he totally misses it Helen draws up
a motive and opportunity grid saying it
reminds her of a clue notepad which
Benoit cringes at because he hates a
really simple party games but in this
regard Helen does end up proving better
at the clue aspect of the sleuthing
process she snoops from room to room she
learns as much as she can about each
person including whiskey which is so
important because whiskey is the one who
tells her that Miles saw her for her
birthday which was two weeks prior
proving that Miles was not in Greece the
whole time showing how he had the
opportunity to kill Andy when Helen and
Benoit check into the bathroom there
actually is a Matisse painting there
that is matisse's Icarus or shadowing
miles flying too close to the Sun and
falling in a heap of flame but that
figure also has a red mark exactly where
Miles will shoot Helen also I love this
detail even more in this scene Bernie's
magazine cover with the gem on her
forehead is reflecting the makeup mirror
clearly seen by benoits he's always
looking down this just shows us how
Benoit is solving two Mysteries at the
same time the actual mystery of who
killed Andy and the dumb manufactured
mystery game that Miles cooked up with
Julian flame in the gym Serena Williams
cameos she's actually Reading gravity's
Rainbow by Thomas pension this was a
book that Benoit referenced it knives
out now when Helen searches Daryl's room
there's a surfboard with a curved a
symbol this is actually an Easter egg
reference to Ryan Johnson's film brick
that was the mystery note with the same
symbol in the word midnight kind of the
big MacGuffin in the movie turns out it
wasn't an a it was the shape of their
immediate spot at a drainage ditch if
you're mad at that being spoiler the
movie came out in 2006 shut up Benoit
breaks down the underlying assumption
that everyone in the room including the
audience had about miles and by just
untying that's not he unlocks the truth
for everyone miles Braun is an idiot yes
like the emperor has no clothes adage
everything we had been attributing to
brilliant conspiracy was actually miles
incompetency his desperate treachery and
is stealing other people's ideas he
stole Andy's idea for Alpha and stole
the cocktail napkin even still Benoit
blanc's idea putting the loaded gun on
the table turning off the lights but
miles burns the original napkin yet
Benoit gives Helen a chunk of the clear
that Miles had talked to him earlier the
same thing if you remember that was also
Within Reach of Andy on the conference
table and she refused to sign miles
clear contract and so Helen the way she
smashed miles box in the opening minutes
smashes up this place she lights a fire
and ignites the clear and then races to
open the glass containing the Mona Lisa
now as the Mona Lisa burns the paint
actually blisters and flakes off
revealing wood underneath because
despite the way the Mona Lisa is shown
in many TV shows and movies Leonardo da
Vinci didn't actually paint the Mona
Lisa on canvas he painted it on wood so
if it were to burn it would really just
be a layer of paint that blisters and
peels off so burning the Mona Lisa yikes
a pretty horrible thing to do it might
remind you of a lot of climate activists
staging these stunts at museums seeming
to deface paintings but as one could
argue for those protesters in the
context of this story Bernie the Mona
Lisa is the most heroic thing Helen can
do because it's the one guarantee she
will have that no one in the world will
ever adopt miles dangerous alternative
fuel it's not just personal Revenge
she's after she really is saving the
world let me know your thoughts in this
movie how did it compare the knives out
for you you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at eavos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]